aujourd'hui avec holly oh non studio on
va pirater le système sonore de toutes
les stations de métro ok c'est bon test
son test sans vous nous entendez
quelqu'un nous entend là oui je crois
qu'on les entend mais je crois que nous
entendons protestation ici décrit il
répète ici victory salut tout le monde
convient de pied ratés des annonces aux
artistes et aux bons profs qui fait
toujours rire et de parler dans le micro
du métro allez on arrêtait de m'embêter
à l'eau
la ligne où
moi c'est moi
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à ceux qui n'ont pas eu le bac vous
savez quoi richer services et pas avoir
des diplômes s'est pas fait de grandes
études c'est pas être médecin ou avocat
il bien gagner sa vie
richir sa vie c'est juste très très
heureux
alors à pauline doivent sécher ses
larmes tu as tu le mets de troller et tu
vas sortir pourquoi pas c'est très bon
et tu apprends vite
[Rires]